[Musique]
bonjour docteur martias mathias wargon
bonjour merci de venir jusqu'à nous vous
êtes urgentistes directeur des urgences
de l'hôpital delafontaine à saint-denis
en région parisienne les alertes sur
l'état des services d'urgence en france
sont constantes près de 20% de ce
service obligé de limiter
leurs activités de filtrer des patients
de fermer parfois dans certaines
situations et des professionnels de
santé annonce un été difficile on parle
de mort qu'il pourrait y avoir on va en
parler avec vous docteur wargon comment
éviter le pire quel est le remède pour
l'hôpital en france alors le remède pour
l'hôpital en fait c'est le remède du
système de santé un les urgences ça
n'est que le symptôme depuis des années
en fait les urgences prennent sur elle
tout ce qui ne marche pas dans le
système de santé c'est à dire avant
l'hôpital la désertification médicale le
manque de médecins traitants et puis
après c'est à dire les manque de lits
dans l'hôpital qui est pas forcément un
manque de lits dans l'hôpital mais
parfois un manque de pouvoir sortir les
patients des lits de l'hôpital et tout
ça bah ça se retrouve aux urgences avec
un mouvement qui avait commencé avant le
coc vide
et puis le vide avec cet immense
mouvement des gens qui quittent leur
travail et tout ça un système déjà très
très fragile ben fini par
par souffrir et par s'effondrer
quelle réaction avant le comte continue
à ce train de mesures annoncées cette
semaine par la ministre de la santé
brigitte bourguignon rappelle les heures
supplémentaires payées double des élèves
infirmiers aides soignants qui n'ayant
pas achevé leur formation peuvent
commencer à travailler sans ayant achevé
leur formation mais n'étant pas dit plus
exactement exactement les soignants
autres étaient volontaires qui peuvent
être être appelés alors comment est ce
que vous réagissez à tout cela là c'est
pas le vide un horse et des mesures du
coc vide alors le doublement des heures
sup il ya aussi une augmentation du
temps additionnel des médecins en fait
c'est des mesures qui dans beaucoup
d'hôpitaux dans beaucoup de régions sont
déjà en cours parce que c'est pas pour
l'été prochain ça se fait déjà deux mois
que ça marche pas le retour des
soignants retraités pourquoi pas mais ça
fait un peu voilà
c'est pas exactement la même chose que
le coc vidya pas une mobilisation
nationale pour une épidémie puis c'est
juillet août les gens vont partir en
vacances et probablement que les élèves
infirmières vont aussi partir en
vacances donc ça fait ça fait un peut
croiser avait un peu rustines ça fait ça
fait mesures d'urgence d'exception dont
certaines sont déjà en cours alors vous
étiez à ce congrès déjà fait quand
madame position opéré après ces annonces
elle a fait ces annonces avant même la
conclusion de cette mission flash
commandé par emmanuel macron qu'est ce
que vous en attendez là la mission flash
j'en attend d'abord des solutions pour
cet été alors on nous promet pas un
énième rapport mais des solutions il se
trouve que françois brood c'est le
président de samu urgences de france 1 1
ou 2 syndiqués avec je le connais très
bien donc moi j'ai confiance en lui mais
je suis très dubitatif
et puis après ce que j'attends c'est
qu'on finisse par dire ok qu'est ce
qu'on fait maintenant tous les étés on
passe en serrant les fesses
tous les étés
chaque été c'est pire que le précédent
alors on passe parce que finalement le
système et les personnels sont très
résignons mais il ya un moment on
passera plus alors je sais pas si c'est
cet été si ce sera l'été prochain mais
il ya un moment ça passera plus si on
n'avait pas à plat la problématique et
regarder ce qu'on fait regardez à quoi
servent les urgences regardez qu'est ce
qu'on fait en médecine de ville et
comment on s'organise différemment la
médecine de ville on va en parler mais
avant cela l'été qui s'annonce quand on
dit que l'été risque d'être difficile
pour qu'on se configure bien la
situation à quoi est ce qu'il faut
penser alors ce qui se passe et ce qui
se passe déjà actuellement c'est qu'il
ya des systèmes et des services
d'urgence qui ferme qui ferment alors
pas de façon continue mais qui ferme la
nuit qui ferment certains jours parce
qu'ils n'ont pas assez nine médecins ça
on connaissait déjà les étés précédents
ni de soignants c'est à dire des infos
des infirmières des aides soignants là
il y en a plus donc on pourra pas ouvrir
ses services d'urgence le risque c'est
qu'ils aient une partie de ce volume là
qu'ils se reposent sur d'autres services
d'urgence et donc avec une surcharge et
donc qu'on ait quelque chose en cascade
en fait en boule de neige et puis le
risque aussi c'est que dans des urgences
surchargées même si la ministre aime pas
qu'on le dise il ya un risque le risque
je sais pas si c'est des morts mais en
tout cas une prise en charge qui est
dégradée et moi mon angoisse c'est que
finalement s'il ya des des accidents en
fait on va pas s'adresser aux directeurs
d'hôpitaux on va pas s'adresser au
ministre on va dire ok c'est la faute de
tel ou tel médecin c'est la faute de tel
ou tel infirmières et quand il y aura
des procès il y aura des départs
l'hôpital la ville la campagne est ce
que il ya une différence de traitement
c'est à dire la médecine de ville par
exemple aujourd'hui en france et on sait
que l est au coeur du système de santé
ars que comment est ce qu'aujourd'hui
elle peut par exemple aider à pallier
les manques dans la mort elle l italie
quand même mais quand on écoute les
médecins généralistes
ils disent tous qu'ils sont débordés
donc s'ils sont débordés ils peuvent pas
y pallier le désert médical
quand on imagine le désert médical on
imagine un petit village au milieu de la
campagne les plus gros déserts médicaux
c'est à paris donc on a alors sauf qu'à
paris il y a une structure hospitalière
beaucoup plus dense qu'à la campagne
donc c'est pour ça que les gens vont aux
urgences mais même à la campagne les
gens vont aux urgences sauf qu'elles
sont plus loin de chez eux après il ya
le fantasme de pouvoir voir tout à côté
de chez soi c'est pas possible on peut
pas avoir l'équivalent d'un chu parisien
et moi je ne suis pas en chu mais dans
n'importe quel endroit ça c'est juste
pas possible mais il faut des relais et
peut-être qu une des solutions passe
aussi par les infirmières et par les
kinés nous on a proposé que ya des
infirmières de pratiques avancées ça
permet aussi aux gens d'évoluer dans
leur travail c'est pas juste pour
pallier au manque c'est pour pouvoir
évoluer dans son travail or les
pratiques avancées concrètes moi ça veut
dire quoi là comme dans d'autres c'est à
d'autres régions il ya ce qu'on appelle
les nurses practitioners c'est à dire
qu'elles peuvent avoir faire des actes
faire des diagnostics en autonomie en
autonomie et pouvoir gérer des patients
à la place des médecins traitants puis à
la téléconsultation alors là telle
consultation c'est pas fantastique pour
tous mais pour un suivi de patients
c'est très bien pour les ehpad ça
pourrait très bien aussi dans cette
affaire est ce qu'il ya une différence
entre le public et le privé il ya
probablement une différence entre le
public et le privé alors d'abord les
urgences du public c'est l'immense
majorité des urgences en france 1 on a
beaucoup beaucoup de public un peu de
privés et encore moins ce qu'on appelle
les espy clé les établissements de en
fait c'est des établissements privés
mais qui font du public on en connaît à
paris comme saint joseph par exemple
qu'il ya des plus connus en france et
donc ces établissements c'est
essentiellement le public qui fait ça le
privé les médecins sont payés à la tâche
mais probablement qu'il faut s'inspirer
le public doit s'inspirer à la fois du
privé de ses établissements privés
participant au service public pour pour
son efficience parce qu'en fait on
embauche des gens on les embauche
tellement mal et on embauche tellement
pas cher que finalement qu'ils ont là on
a soit des gens qui ont la foi chevillée
au corps et on en a beaucoup soit des
gens qui se disent ok je vais aller dans
le public mais qui sont pas les plus
efficaces a doctor aaron puisque vous
parlez d'argent je tente la question
est-ce que or et paréo soigner les
urgences en france c'est une affaire
d'argent c'est aussi une affaire
d'argent mais ce n'est pas qu'une
affaire d'argent c'est à dire que faire
venir des gens les faire rester c'est de
l'argent et henri selon les régions ben
c'est pas la même chose et puis mais
vous vous levez pas le matin parce que
vous avez votre feuille de paye à la fin
du mois ça ça marche quelques jours
quelques semaines quelques mois mais pas
avis il vaut le travail vous use si le
travail ne vous épanouie pas si vous
avez des mauvaises conditions de travail
une mauvaise qualité de vie au travail
vous ne resterez pas et d'ailleurs on le
voit mais pas que dans la santé on voit
les gens qui partent parce qu'ils
supportent plus le travail quitte à
gagner moins faut qu'on se résume de
personnel dévoué mais épuisés résilient
certains n'aiment pas trop ce mot
maintenant alesi lyon c'est vrai mais
quoi exactement
s'ajoute à cela un manque de
reconnaissance pour son entendu des
soignants se plaint d'un manque de de
reconnaissance dont beaucoup sont partis
comment les faire revenir on va peut
être s'arrêter à un cas spécifique les
personnels non vaccinés qui ont été
obligés de partir ou éloignés d'eux
les à personne les a obligés de partir
il suffisait de se vacciner alors la
personne est obligée de parole à venir
ça personnel mais en fait c'est un faux
c'est un faux débat ce débat là il est
même pas c'est même pas un débat
épidémiologique c'est même pas un débat
sur est-ce qu'il faut les faire revenir
parce qu'on manque demain on estime
qu'il y en a quinze mille dont sait même
pas combien être soignés en dedans parce
qu'il ya des secrétaires il ya des
ouvriers il ya plein de gens dedans
quinze mille si on compte les hôpitaux
les cliniques les les services de soins
de suite et de réadaptation
on doit être dans les 6000
établissements à peu près
voilà on va faire
et puis le problème c'est plutôt un
problème à la fois de
professionnalisme 2 qu'est ce que c'est
qu'être soignants et il ya quand même
des devoirs et les devoirs c'est de se
vacciner et qu'est-ce qu'on fait la
prochaine fois à la prochaine épidémie
on vaccine personnes la grippe on
vaccine personnes est ce que la mauvaise
santé des urgences est un mal français
docteur margolis que en europe il ya des
modèles de meilleure gestion dont on
pourrait s'inspirer ouais il ya
probablement des modèles de meilleure
gestion des modèles de civisme
différents en angleterre on a les mêmes
problèmes voir c'est pire en fait
il ya les piles du nord c'est un modèle
qu'on essaie d'explorer où les gens
finalement une régulation avant de venir
aux urgences
qui est donc qu'ils appellent un service
qui va les orienter vers la meilleure
structure qui n'est pas forcément ça
aide d urgence aux pays bas et je veux
pas dire de bêtises parce que je connais
pas bien ça mais je crois savoir qu'en
fait vous êtes orienté aux urgences par
votre médecin traitant mais pour ça faut
avoir un médecin traitant donc il ya des
modèles de régulation la question du
modèle de régulation et s'est pas
empêché de venir les gens au fait
revenir les gens urgence c'est proposer
une solution quand la seule solution
c'est urgent ce pas finalement c'est
urgence puisque donc il faut que la
régulation elle et des propositions pour
citer des collègues mais tient à vos la
bobologie n'existe pas un ange enfin ça
veut rien dire lago biologie quand vous
avez une otite pour moi médecin
urgentiste et de la bobologie mais pour
la personne qui a une otite c'est pas de
la bobologie mais il faut pas venir aux
urgences pourquoi parce que je suis nul
en au titre
et si c'est pas une otite ici il faut un
suivi et ben demain vous revenez aux
urgences pour votre suivi vous n'allez
pas me voir moi vous allez vous un de
mes collègues qui vous connaît pas qui
connaît pas bien votre dossier ça a été
vu rapidement c'est pas de la bonne
médecine la médecine la la la médecine
de faible gravité mots que je préfère à
la bobologie aux urgences mais qui va
nécessiter un suivi c'est comme si vous
alliez manger tous les jours chez mcdo
et ben mcdo c'est bien quand vous vous
nourrissez correctement c'est pas grave
vous pouvez y aller une fois c'est
rigolo c'est sympa si vous nourrissez
tous les jours en fast food c'est pour
le moins de 20 ces problématiques et
c'est mauvais pour la santé c'est la
même chose les urgences merci beaucoup
mais je vous remercie docteur mathias
vardon d'être venu jusqu'à nos
urgentistes délétère des urgences de
l'hôpital delafontaine à saint-denis ce
était l'invité de paris ait pas de
journée à vous bonne journée at au son